so I want to start by saying what I said
to you in Toronto and I want to say it
again right now it's one of my favorite
films of the year I saw it again last
night James Mangold directed the [ __ ]
out of this it's so so good sorry for
myself that's good um I am curious
though for the two of you I really enjoy
both of your work sincerely a lot and
I'm curious do you ever before filming
begins do you ever get like nervous
about doing a scene or are you sort of
like that ever still happen to you
happens all the time if something's
wrong with you if you don't get nervous
about it you've got to get nervous about
it it's nerve-racking it's hard to get
up in front of people and act and acting
on film well the challenges are
different than acting on stage but it's
still very challenging it can be very
exacting it's the easiest job in the
world until it's not until suddenly it's
very hard and suddenly it's like wow I
got to perform laser surgery here
everybody back up
yeah it's very nerve-wracking yeah
nervous terrifying all of it I think you
go through all of it and I think that
anything that you you care deeply about
is incredibly nerve-racking and scary
and yeah I would hate it if it were any
different I would really worry if I ever
walked in so well I got this slick to
watch this guys yeah I think you know I
think I think he we just you got a care
I don't want to do spoilers and give
anything away but there is a scene in
the movie with you in a car that I abs
one of my favorite scenes in the whole
film of you reacting to something can
you sort of talk about filming that
scene and you know just that the
emotions that you're sort of putting on
screen and it's so awesome it's a great
scene it's great scene on paper I mean
it was a great when you read the
screenplay you're like oh this is one of
the standouts
in the movie it was great fun to do Matt
and I shot it all day long he's a great
scene partner and Jim did a great job of
you know Jim and I didn't talk a lot
about what needed to happen in the scene
before we shot the scene I think we both
kind of understood what the scene was
about and then Jim really helped by
creating the circumstances that allowed
the scene to flow I mean we're in a car
and we're going really fast and the car
stops and the cameras were already
mounted on the car and we can proceed
with the scene from there so we shot it
all day Jim tells me we mainly use the
first take that's mainly what you're
seeing and somebody asked once if Jim
and I had talked about how long things
needed to go in the scene before the
scene started to change or we didn't
talk about any of that it was all pretty
intuitive it was kind of kind of there
on the page like I say for both of you
and I'm sorry for asking so much about
acting but nothing else there's so much
I'm so fascinated by process and how
actors do what they do do you find it
that you can maintain that sort of
emotional because you're giving so much
of yourself when you're doing an
emotional scene or you're putting
yourself out there do you find it like
after a few takes like the tank is dry
or can you continually hit those
emotional beats that you need to hit you
know yeah I don't know about tank dry
yeah I look I've been there I've been in
in in in in situations where I feel like
wow there was something sort of
happening kind of in in the first few
takes that isn't quite you know
happening now I'm Agatha I guess I've
been there before III - for me
personally I'd like to do it all day I
mean I I love doing and I think there's
constantly new things you can find it's
really you know only somewhat about you
and what you're feeling it's mostly
about that the other person and how your
your your
you're affecting them and it's it for me
it's it's that's a real game that's the
real fun and the real joy is to try to
kind of create something together and
look for what's going on in the other
person I think the wealth of the the
wealth of stuff is really not about you
it's about what you can draw out of out
of that my prefer for me
we'll set Toronto